Rhianna hits up the Grammys after-party  with rumoured boyfriend  Hassan Jamil  [Music]  the 29 year old songbird was spotted  leaving one oak nightclub in New York  City on Sunday night shortly after her  reported flame that's the Saudi  businessman exiting the club at 3:45  a.m. and that's RiRi rocking a different  look than the one she wore earlier in  the night when she accepted the Grammy  for Best rap/sung performance with  Kendrick Lamar thank you can drink  forgiving me this incredible opportunity  to be on such a great record Jamil kept  things a little more cash in a gray  t-shirt and black hoodie the pair was  first linked in June when they were  spotted kissing in Spain and have since  been seen together in London and Boston  Rihanna  even sparked engagement rumours in  December when she sported a sizable  diamond on her ring finger to Chris Rock  show at Madison Square Garden in New  York City  [Music]